*Van doors opening and closing*
Hey!
Hey! HEY!!
*smack*
You can't fall asleep in here!
It's hot!
It's like really hot!
*disappointed sigh*
This fan was working yesterday...
You want some water?
Ah
Okay, got the fan goin'
That's a little bit at least
Lemme start up the car, get the AC goin'
We got a lot to do today, so
Might as well get to it bright and early
*exhale*
Why were you sleeping in here by the way?
(idk dude)
This feel warm?
Here feel this:
Ah
That's not good
Problem: That fan ain't gonna cut it
It's roasting hot in here
Chica's not gonna survive if we have to be in this hot car this whole time
And, uh, the air conditioning doesn't work
*pop*
God dammit!
I just bought it!
*voiceover* Loser
*Sounds of markimoo being cutoff while he's goin' up some stairs*
Ok
So it's hot
But not that hot
A wise man once said:
bdrdrdrabapa
dupotatapu
bdrdrdrapapa
due-man-not-hot
Yeah
Ah who needs this bullshit
*smack x4*
I can't write on a wet surface, it won't work
So
*sniped*
We've got-
*yodeling*
A Problem™
Haaaaa
pbpbpbpb
*mark from the future* loser
*grunting*
Hanzo: Ryuu ga waag teki wo kurau!
Its so hot the inks not writing on the board, it's not because I sprayed it with water like an idiot.
That s- can't be the reason why
Its
Hoooooooooooo-
*inhale*
-ooooooot
It's hot
*smack*
As you can plainly see
We got this van to be mobile, if you remember on the board-that I just fucking wiped off, why didn't I just keep that?
Ah
Dudn't matter
Don't worry about it, that's my problem not your problem- and we got this van to be mobile but
We can't go anywhere cuz
?
Frankly I'm worried about Chica more than I'm worried about me. Chica where are you?
Spell it out, spell it out-
H
O
T?
HOT. So how, do we solve this problem?
Hold my sign.
*Edited stomping*
Alright, so I got this thing it's called the hyper cool with a K-E-W-L
I hate that. Ok.
But here's how it works; so evaporative cooling products are designed for people working or playing in the summer heat
Work is play for us, so that's good.
Products are easy to use, submerge in water for 1 to 2 minutes into
*Mumbling* I don't have 1 to 2 minutes.
Okay...
Alright well fine.
Give it a soak
(Dude, what the hell?)
One to two minutes! Be patient, okay?
Ahhh All right. So we've got a temporary solution, but it's not gonna do us any good. Water?
Cool.
And uh for Chica- Hey, how about we drape this around your neck. It's gonna keep you nice and cool
Okay? But just for a little bit. So, what we gotta do-
Is we've got to quickly find something for Chica that's gonna be more than just this towel
Because this isn't gonna keep her cool for long; She's gonna
need water, she's gonna need a better bed, we're gonna need some kind of solution to fix the AC
Uhhh, where's my whiteboard?
Imma comin' back there
Excuuuuse me!
It's hot. But, I bet you didn't know, that I was actually making this into an anagram.
H. O. T,  which stands for Heat, Over..... Thought.
Which means that heat, is just in your mind.
High, Oxygen, Temperature. Heat actually stands for High Oxygen Temperature.
It's really only the oxygen that has any heat in it.
Uh, so if we didn't breathe oxygen, we would never actually get hot.
But unfortunately we live in a universe where,
Uh,
Hot, Ox- Heavy Oxidised Teflon. You know what I'm saying?
Step- Step number H:
'How do cold?'
'Cause, this is what- Wait, no, I'm just realising-
Oh, how- No-
H-Ha-How- No, hang on- Wait-
H. O. T- How...- How,
Ooooooh, Temperature?
We need a way to measure the temperature.
You buckled up back there? Ha, you don't have a seatbelt- LOSER!
Hoooo- ah, that's scary-
Still getting used to this van.
Who you gonna call, bub? *In Chica voice* Aaaamy, that's who!
I know who has- Oh, hi!
A: Hello?
M: Hi, how's it going?
A: It's good, how're you?
M: I'm pretty good. Uh- it's really hot.
A: Yeah.
M: Yeah.
A: It's toasty!
A: It's a toasty day.
M: Uh, do you remember that, like, laser gun thing?
A: Yeah, I have it- I always have it on me.
M: Oh... Cool?
A: I always have it.
M: Okay!
A: I sleep with it.
M: That's weird- Oh-
A: Always.
A: Yeah I got it.
M: Okay, cool.
*Honks horn* *Mark cringes at the noise*
I've never horned!
M: Hii!
A: Hi Bepis!
M: Hey, we got, uh- we got a- I got a cute dog.
A: *To Chica* Oh, careful baby!
M: Okay, so uh,
A: What's the plan?
M: The AC doesn't work in this van.
A: I can tell.
M: Yeah, so it's really hot. But-
A: You wanna know how hot? Specifically?
M: Yes I would like that very much, thank you.
A: 98° on your leg.
M: Really? Good god.
A: 98!
M: It's roasting in here.
A: You wanna try it?
M: Yeah. Shine it right in my eyes, please.
M: Don't! Oh god! I don't wanna die!
M: Alright so, umm, can you give me my whiteboard?
M: Alright, we solved for 'H'- Which is 'How do cold?'
M: So we need to solve for 'O'- Which is...
A: October.
M: True.
M: Okay.
A: It's hot?
M: 'Hot'? Question mark?
A: That's weird, right?
M: Yeah it is weird.
M: She's not doing so hot. Haaa!
A: Ha! Good one.
*Door slamming*
M: I should've gone that way.
A: Yes, you should've.
M: Aahhhhhhhhh... Cuck.
A: You could probably bang a U-ey in this.
M: Oooooh!
Nailed it.
M: Nice van, right?
A: It's a good van.
M: Yeah.
M: Did you come up with a name for it?
M: No? (Yes, Jim)
M: *Loud sirens in background* Oh, let me over- There's frickin' emergencies everywhere!
M: Let me over. x2
A: I'm panicking.
*Extremely loud sirens*
M: AHHHHHHHH!
A: It's so hot, my knees- My kneepits start to sweat.
M: What kinda reading are you in in those kneepits?
A: Oh, get the back of my kneepit-
M: *exhale* That says 106!
A: (laughing)
A: Oh, don't hit this woman..!
M: Ooohhhhhhh!
M: Okay so we're at the pet store, 'cause, Chica always comes first. In everything. Right Chica?
M: Isn't that right girl? You always come first. You're always special. And you're probably very hot.
M: But this is a store where you can go in! Righty-ho.
M: Let's go do it.
M: Chica, pick your favourite.
M: Awwwww!
A: Awww, that's cute!
A: Ooh!
M: That one? You like that?
M: Alright! Oh, oh, oh-
M: So,
A: It wouldn't work on me!
M: What we've got going on here is that we've got Chica all settled.
We got her water, we got her a bed, we got her a bowl.
*Sigh* But we've still got a few other problems.
We need to solve the air conditioner problem. I've never fixed an air conditioner? But how hard could it be, right?
M: Right?
M: ...Right?
Chica come here!
M: Do you want some water? That's a good girl.
Oh yeah.
Good girl. Good water?
Even that water's getting a toasty 84°.
M: Your hair is 105.
A: Oh shit.
M: Look at my face.
M: Ah!
A: Oh Mark, we can't go to... to big box store...
A: With a dog...
M: We can....
M: We cannot....
*Door slam*
M: Here's a story. Uh, we're at concentric circle store,
M: I looked up a tutorial on the internet about how to replace AC refrigerent.
M: ..In this van- to make it cool in here.
M: I'm going to trust you, with the vehicle!
A: Ohh no.
M: Don't take it for a joyride now. Alright!
[snazzy tunes]
M: They didn't have any. Their car selection was reduced by their buporium(??).
M: They uhh-
A: Don't talk shit about the buporium (??)
M: I'm talking shit about the buporium. (??)
M: Why don't we go to, uhh-
A: Watch out!
M: Oh, shit.
A: Which way does it-
M: Well that's not gonna cover it all!
M: Aeohhhhhh!
M: So we've got the 'H', we've got the 'O',
M: ...Now we need the 'T',
M: Which stands for, Technooology...
M: Hey, funny thing; This vest smells really bad.
A: Why?
M: I dunno.
M: That's pristine! If there's one thing that can quench your thirst on a hot summer's day,
M: ...Actually it's Fall but let's ignore that fact.
M: It's none other than the- Oh! Nevermind.
A: We could go ice-skating! That would be cool!!
M: OOOOOOOOOOOH!
M: Hop
M: Same story. We'll by right back.
M: Chica, you be good. *Kiss*
*Door slam*
[more snazzy music]
*Door opening*
M: We got what we needed! We got AC Pro, it says 'No. 1 rated coldest air.'
M: And, I don't know about you but I trust this guy on the bottle.
M: So I'm gonna trust him with my life and I'm gonna put this in this car.
M: Could you get the temperature gage?
M: You never know when it's gonna fluctuate, and at any moment it could just blow, so I got a critical, critical knowledge.
It is supposed to be on when I do this.
Okay... that looks safe.
Am I gonna be able to break these? Ho. I got it!
Oh, no I'm not gonna risk that.
You know what? This is totally fine.
Maybe I should read this?
I'm ready, you're ready,
'Unscrew and remove', it says.
For the record, I am not a car guy.
I've never been a car guy. I went to engineering school,
...That doesn't mean I know cars.
Don't... assume anything about me.
My knowledge is incredibly limited.
Righty-ho! Maybe I should lift- there's more instructions here.
Eugh! Let's give that a gander.
Okay, alright, cool, okay, alright, got it, great
Pop this bad boy- Alright,
..That was a weird reading!
...Is that what it's supposed to be?
That seemed too quick. Ambient(?) outside temperature, ohhh!
What temperature is it now? Just point it straight up!
Ahh, crisp!
Man, I should've read all the instructions before I started doing this. Haha! No.
'If the compressor is cycled on and pressure is in the red, do not attempt to recharge- seek professional help'
Oh! Was I supposed to shake this?
Eh.
Good enough.
I've always loved explosions. I'll just let it go-
What happens, happens!
The guy said it could take up to 8 minutes so maybe I'm just being a little bitch here.
Ah, 'Shake can well'.
....Probably important.
A: How goes it?
M: It was scary at first but now I realise it's just gonna take a while.
A: Do you know how this works?
M: Yeah, yeah- I get it, um-
M: So, the- the- that's- like, uh- and then- which is like, the uh- huh?
A: We solved the cooling issue by the sun going down.
M: That is handy dandy!
M: Huh?
Stranger: Does that really work?
M: Yeah, it's- It's getting there. Hopefully, anyway,
M: I've never done this before, so.
Stranger: Oh, okay.
M: I'm just assuming.
[snazzy music: the third edition]
M: I just read something on the sign, that said 'Always wear protective goggles and gloves.'
Oooh, we are-
Ohhhh! That was the longest go yet.
*Slam*
M: Ohhh, get the temperature reader!
M: Read the temperature on those vents.
A: Ohhhhh yes!
M: (proud laughter) Yeah!
A: Wooh!
M: I've never done that before! It worked!
M: Look at Chica. It worked!
A: It worked!
M: Uh oh
A: Oh boy!
M: (laughing)
A: I guess I'm out-y!
M: I can't believe it! That was so scary!
It may need some more soon because it emptied this can just to get into the green, but
A: Yep.
M: That was not bad. I could do that again!
We could do that again!
M: Hell yeah *bonk* Oh!
*Mario dying sound effect*
*dog toy*
M: Oh hey, old lady! Bonk.
M: So now, the only thing left to do is we gotta...
M: We gotta, well we gotta pick a name! 'Cause I think- I think you had something in mind.
M: ...And I think it was a good one.
M: So, it's been a fun day. And, thank you so much Amy for helping out.
M: We got the heat problem solved, but I think that also got solved when the sun went down.
But nonetheless, there was one person out there- King Stevens Games-
M: Uh... Said 'your van's inside looks like you're sitting inside a barrel'
M: And...
M: I really wanna take this thing to Cracker Barrel.
M: So, I think in honour of that, we've gotta name it 'Barrel'
M: And, uh...
A: The Barrel!
M: The Barrel!
A: The Barreeeel!
M: Climb in the Barrel! We're gonna take the Barrel down the Falls!
A: Don't take the Barrel down the Falls...
M: Take the Barrel down the Falls.
M: You don't think this bad boy would float?
M: Honestly you, you deserve the right to Christen this lovely Barrel
*Bonk*
M: Okay...
A: *laughing*
*Bonk*
M: Okay, well-
A: That's a real dent..
M: Alright...
*Angry-ish dad sound*
M: I guess you left your mark either way- Hah!
A: That's your name!
M: That's my name.
A: Good one!
M: ...Crack open the bubbler?
[sexy music 10/10]
M: Alright! So, thank you so much for joining me,
M: Uh, this was a lot of fun- Thank you Amy!
A: Yeah!
M: Thank you Chica!
A: Say you're welcome, bub!
M: ...I don't think she can...
M: But uh, most importantly; Thank you.
M: And uh, as always- I will see you in the next video.
M: Buh-bye!
A: Byee!
*boinks*